the world is still reacting after
nuclear inspectors from the united
nations warned that a catastrophic
incident could happen at the zeppelian
nuclear power plant in ukraine since
russian troops took control of the
facility early in the war kiev and
moscow have been accusing each other of
risking a disaster by shelling the site
europe's largest nuclear facility is now
disconnected from the grid after
shelling cut its external power lines
for the time being it's running on
backup diesel generators but there are
concerns about what could happen if the
generators failed or ran out of fuel the
head of ukraine's nuclear agency says
the government is considering switching
off the entire station before any
and this can lead to an incident
with damage to the active zone of the
reactor
that would release radioactive material
into the environment
it would have consequences not only for
ukraine
it would surely have consequences beyond
the country's borders
it's something we must avoid
and i'm now happy to welcome charles
casto he's a nuclear safety expert and
worked in japan for a year following the
fukushima nuclear accident in 2011. dr
casto then served as the american
government's lead nuclear representative
mr casto welcome to the day first up how
big do you think the danger of a nuclear
disaster is right now at the zaparija
power plant
well thanks for having me on nicole well
the danger is it's unprecedented
to have this situation
nuclear power plants are not designed to
be operated in a war zone so it's
definitely a dangerous situation that
must be monitored and prepared we must
prepare for
any eventuality that could happen at
that station
there has been a lot of talk though
about the plant being quite robust that
a plane could potentially crash onto it
and the structure could withstand the
impact what if a missile actually did
strike a reactor
well as you said nicole they have been
tested for that and it would take quite
a impact for anything
to hurt the reactor itself what i worry
more about is the dry
fuel storage that's nearby in canisters
concrete canisters at the facilities
those can essentially become what we
always call a dirty bomb and and may
limit the access to the facility which
would cause even more problems if the
access is limited to the reactors
and and
providing them power and water
you demand ideas and leadership to
protect the plant does that mean that
you're not seeing enough of that
well i would i would do more i would
plan as an extreme crisis leader i would
always get ahead of the accident you
must get ahead of it you must
expand your capabilities and you must
have act faster than the accident does
so
i've called for a staging area for a
rescue mission for the reactor should
something happen we learned that at
fukushima at a staging area called j
village
away from the station about 10 miles
away from the station or 18
somewhere around 8 10 to 18 miles away
from the station and i i would do
something similar here where you could
store the diesel
diesel fuel that they were talking about
we need deep more diesel fuel for
emergency diesel generators where you
can store other sand other equipment
that you would use to rescue the reactor
in the event of an accident
now ukraine says it might have to shut
down the planned altogether would that
lower any of those risks that you just
named
it would nicole the plants operate
at full power normally and when they
shut down they still generate
electricity uh heat much as a pot on
your stove when you shut off the stove
the pot still is hot
and you have to remove that heat but the
longer you go the more heat that
dissipates and the less hazard there is
so shutting down the reactors we and the
saying always is
the safest reactor is a shutdown reactor
switching off europe's biggest nuclear
power plant i'd imagine that's not as
easy as it sounds though how would that
work
well it's easy to shut down the reactors
is easy the electrical supply that's
more difficult to make adjustments to
that especially if you wanted to divert
that electric supply
the the same thing happened in japan
when you started out with 54 reactors
and eventually within the year or so all
the reactors were shut down and the
country readjusted its electrical supply
to accommodate the shutdown of all those
reactors and in the ukraine right now
unfortunately there's not much
electrical demand
would the workers have to stay behind
because there is a lot of concern about
them politicians have said that they're
not workers anymore that they are there
as hostages that they are working at
gunpoint would people who now work there
have to remain to oversee the facility
well that's another option is to have
someone in the staging area that can go
in and replace those operators
and the news from the iea mission is
fairly positive on that they
conclude that the operators ukrainian
operators are still in command of the
reactors
so that's that's very positive there so
at this point but my uh position is
there should be some contingency should
something happen
where the operators are either overly
fatigued
or are not able to to respond to the to
the reactors
now for the situation at hand if the
electricity were to cut out while the
plant is still operational what would
happen
well as as was talked about earlier the
emergency diesel generators would run
and they have about a 10-day supply
of diesel fuel and more on the station
now and by at that point the seven
percent decay heat as we call it the
decay heat would greatly dissipate so it
would be much less of a threat after
that 10 days or beyond
nuclear safety expert charles casto
thank you so much for those insights
thank you